بيرند هوفمان هو بالضبط هنا
رئيس أكبر نادي مشجعين للبايرن
تمت دعوتهم هنا من قبل قطر إلى
هذه البطولة ولكن حتى لو لم تفعل
يدفع الكثير لدرجة أنه يؤلم حقًا
الليلة أو هذا بالطبع
يؤلمك حقًا عندما تحب كرة القدم
هو ومثل زيارات BAM هي أ
تسليط الضوء على حياة كرة القدم بعد ذلك
بالطبع تريد أيضًا أن تذهب إلى أبعد من ذلك
ممكن تعال وزيارة مرة أخرى
أربع سنوات في الجولة التمهيدية
لتركه يؤلم كثيرا
الكبير كله في ألمانيا
مهتم بالتقارير التي تفيد بأن المعجبين
تم شراؤها هم أغاني المعجبين
لديهم عمليا كل الألمان
المشجعين فيما بينهم ما الذي لديك من أجله
الحقوق والواجبات أيضا كما fernleder
الذي تمت دعوته
كان لدينا حقوق فقط
لا واجبات حقا نحن
يمكن أن تتحرك بحرية كما في أي
بلد آخر لدي شعبي
قال نحن ضيف في شخص غريب
البلد وهذا كيف نتصرف و
عملت بشكل جيد في كل مكان
اللطف والود لدي
مثال صغير كنت على ذلك
سوق مع زملائي الثلاثة وبعد ذلك
جاء اثنان من العرب الذين أخذونا على الفور
دعوة والجدول ننظر إلينا
القهوة والكعك تبرعت ولديها
ألمانيا أنتم أصدقائنا و
التي حققت أداءً جيدًا وفوق كل شيء
ما عمل جيدا انتظر هؤلاء
كأس العالم في مدينة أيضا
لديك معجبين من 32 دولة
يجب أن يعرف ويقدر ويحب
وكان من الرائع أنهم ليسوا كذلك
لأول مرة كان مخلفات مع
بايرن ميونيخ عدة مرات هنا و
هي بالطبع على علم أيضًا بـ
حالة حقوق الإنسان ومعرفة البلد
كان هذا موضوعًا كبيرًا اعتادوا طرحه
جفل عندما تلقوا الدعوة
ليس على الإطلاق أردنا الذهاب على أي حال
قطر اذهب نعم كانت الخطط قيد التنفيذ
لبضعة أشهر ثم جاء
بين ذلك سئلت
فقط أنفذ هذا أنا نفسي
بالطبع مع 32 يمثلها
32 مشاركا معلومات كاملة
حدث عظيم وعندما أكون بعد ذلك
المرة الثانية سألت حسنا فعلت
أفعل ذلك لأنني أعرف الكثير من الناس
هنا أعرف الألمانية التي أعرفها
السكان المحليين أعرف كيف هو هنا
أعيش وأنا أعلم كيف يقدرونهم
لأنهم يقدرون وهذا هو سبب ذلك
لا يوجد موضوع على الإطلاق لقطر
تعال لم نكن بحاجة إلى أي شيء ونحن
لم يكن علينا التوقيع على أي شيء
يمكن أن يتحرك بحرية كان هناك واحد
لقد أمضينا وقتًا رائعًا هنا
وأخبروا ذلك أيضًا
لقد تحدثت حقوق الإنسان بالتأكيد
كيف بدا ذلك بالطبع نحن في
أول زيارة لأول مرة
لدينا 32 ممثلا من المعجبين
اطرح الأسئلة بصراحة واطلب منهم
استجوبنا عن كل شيء
قالوا بالطبع كل ميت
عدد كبير جدًا ولكنه أيضًا
أعطتها ألمانيا العشرة الأخيرة
6000 سنة قتلت في مواقع البناء أيضا
كل واحد لديه الكثير من هذه
ظروف العمل بالطبع
العمال الذين يرسلون كل شهر
80٪ من رواتبهم المنزل فورا و
انطلق مع الـ 20٪ التي لا يزال لديهم
داخل ال
ثم تأتي الظروف الأشد فقراً
وسائل الإعلام بالطبع والحفاظ على نقاء و
قل أن هذا ليس جيدًا لك
يحدث نعم ، لقد انتهينا حقًا
يمكن أن تتحدث عن أي شيء وليس لدينا
تم حظره لأن الردود المجانية بالمجان
الحديث عن هذا ما عشناه هنا
لذلك لديك شيء لك على أي حال
رحلة ناجحة كانت رحلة لطيفة
نزهة هي ذكرى ل
الذي يبقى معنا لفترة طويلة لأنه
كانت كأس العالم ، ولسوء الحظ لدينا
المنتخب الألماني ككل الوحيد
كان بعيدًا جدًا عما لم يكن مثلهم
لا يحب الآخرون رؤيتهم
مدعوم فقط في اللعبة
[تصفيق]